Pompeii kind of feels like a movie that
would come out in like 1998 when
Hollywood was obsessed with volcano
movies remember Dante's Peak starring
Pierce Brosnan and volcano with Tommy
Lee Jones this movie would fit in right
there just perfectly Pompeii stars Kit
Harington Emily Browning Kiefer
Sutherland carrie-anne moss and Jared
Hess now what this movies about is the
town of Pompeii and the inevitable
destruction by a volcano now we know
this story we've heard it before the
volcano explodes and all that stuff we
know what's gonna happen basically we
don't know how they're gonna tell the
story it's kind of like Titanic going to
Titanic knowing Titanic's gonna sink
it's about how they tell the story is it
gonna be exciting is it gonna be fun are
you gonna be invested in the characters
or the special effects gonna blow us
away none of these things happen in
Pompeii I can assure you of that
as I said this movie is directed by Paul
WS Anderson who's probably best known
for his Resident Evil movies he's not
really one of my favorite directors I'm
not a hater like you know what I mean
like if he made a good movie I'd say
that's a good movie he just doesn't
really make good movies I would say the
closest I've ever gotten to liking one
of his films was event horizon I've
actually really enjoyed about the first
half of that movie and then once the
plot really kicked in two just went
insane and not the right ways Pompeii is
the kind of movie where as you watch it
you slowly start to realize that this is
a movie that this director is trying to
make with special effects that he can't
quite afford it's like he's trying to
include a special effect in almost every
single shot to the point where you start
to realize that almost everything on the
screen is fake and it doesn't look
convincing there are a lot of movies
with great background CGI where you
don't even notice like if you actually
watch this video online about the wolf
of Wall Street and the special effects
that were in that movie there were an
absurd amount of special effects in that
movie that I never even noticed in
Pompeii it honestly looks like
straight-to-dvd special effects there
are moments where the volcanoes
exploding where you're like okay that
looks pretty convincing but for the most
part the special effects in this movie
are extremely subpar like there's a
scene where the volcanoes exploding and
the main characters on a horse and he's
running forward towards this chariot and
the ground is crumbling beneath him and
the volcanoes in the background and
debris is flying everywhere and the
green screen behind him is obvious that
he's just standing on some sort of a
mcann
thing that makes him go up and down and
everything else in the shot is CGI and
it just comes to the point where
absolutely nothing is convincing in this
movie and I actually started to laugh
there are moments in this movie where
characters are injured by debris or by
fire or lava or whatever and where it's
supposed to be kind of frightening and
harrowing it's filmed in such a way that
was so incredibly fake and the stunt
work was so terrible that my friend and
I were laughing we couldn't stop
laughing in fact we were trying so hard
not to annoy people around us but there
are moments in this movie that are
laughably bad this movie really copies
off gladiator it basically is gladiator
until it turns into Dante's Peak setback
in the older days it's basically the
best way that I can describe this movie
the scenes in the gladiator ring are
terribly filmed I mean there are some
moments where you'd be like okay this
action is awesome but it's like he cuts
every time someone hits or moves
themselves it's not shaky-cam
it doesn't look bad like the shots are
composed all right it's just that he
cuts every time someone strikes or moves
there are so many cuts for one fight
scene that you cannot really piece
together what is happening in your mind
you're just watching a mindless string
of shots in which something
subconsciously is telling you that two
people are fighting but if you actually
sit down and watch the shots it doesn't
look right it just doesn't look right
now I'm not saying that every movie with
a fight scene has to have a long take
I'm just talking about don't cut every
time someone goes gene cut ding cut cut
and I'm not exaggerating that is how
many cuts are in these fight scenes and
it starts to really numb your brain the
acting in the movie is mostly terrible
Kit Harington from Game of Thrones
I hear he's excellent on that show I
have not gotten a chance to watch that
show yet trust me I know you would like
me to watch it many people have told me
too and I probably will one day because
I've heard nothing but good things about
it but in this movie he's pretty much
emotionless so when he's in the fight
scenes you don't get a sense of urgency
on his face at all he's just very very
bland in this movie most of the acting
is especially Kiefer Sutherland as the
villain he is truly awful in this movie
I'm talking about total hammy cheesy
everything about his dialogue is
terrible it's just that in this movie
under this
direction most of these actors suck it's
not entertaining
I was not enthralled in any way I wasn't
into any of the characters and the
special effects that maybe could then be
like okay look we have some fun CGI
images to look at this is gonna be
entertaining those aren't even very good
so none of it really works at all there
is one good fight scene in this movie
that I enjoyed during a gladiator
sequence that was fairly well done like
maybe a few brief little moments where I
was like okay that actually felt pretty
good
that was actually directed fairly well
why isn't the rest of the movie directed
like that for that reason I'm gonna give
Pompeii a d-minus really nothing about
this movie worked for me so guys the
movies coming out in about a week if you
see the movie let me know what you
thought of it as always guys thank you
so much for watching and if you like
this you can click right here and get
stuck mine eyes
[Music]